hey don't Chris I'm doing well man how
are you I wanted to call you because you
did a thing in Afghanistan I've heard
you tell the story where you managed to
get a whole bunch of people on a
conference call clued in and it wasn't
like this I just want to know just tell
me how you did it because you know even
though we have a little company I just
want you to remind me how you do it
because I think it's something that I
could use yeah absolutely
and in the spirit of home isolation
you'll hear my kids fighting in the
background so go with it the yeah it's
it's and now this is more critical than
ever right so I had a bunch of these
conversations the last two weeks or so
the first thing that leaders at any
level in the organization got to talk to
your people right when when I work for
Stan McChrystal
we started with we were sort of that
world the military's first really remote
workforce he's back in Afghanistan when
this is the height of Afghanistan right
well really the peak of the war in Iraq
is where this in fact 2005 is where this
started to get traction and it's spread
the Afghanistan around the world
what McChrystal have to do is separate
us and put us really close to this
network problem we had Al Qaeda's a
network now we have Cova doesn't network
- everybody's working from home to fight
this this this network spread same thing
and so we're crystal quickly realize I'm
gonna lose any sort of cohesion here if
I don't figure out another way to
communicate with these folks the ways we
would all like top-down an email and
stuff top-down sort of structure then
you double down on sort of email flow
that you get an email from command that
says I need you to do this and the
general will tell the Colonel's and I
need you guys to do this and the game of
telephone goes on exactly and then and
then they also roll themselves into well
the generals will do a you know Skype
meeting and then our version of that
same thing and then just everybody
schedule they're staring at screens all
day okay and so he recognized hey we
have to be like a small team but with
like 20,000 people around the world and
so started implementing not by mandate
but by invite I'm going to
one big meeting at a pace that keeps up
with this problem and for us that was
24/7 and I would argue that's that's the
pace for most people right now so at
this time every single day I'm gonna be
on this net and if you want to join join
and I'm gonna talk honestly about what
I'm saying you tell me what's going on
the ground at cetera it was super
experimental and I didn't understand it
what you think anyway anyway and people
any you know civilian organization
eventually we had our coalition partners
I mean this grew to seven or eight
thousand people a day on a platform like
this 24/7 for years on end I didn't
really appreciate it I grown up in my
little small team silo and the boss was
like seven levels up and then I
distinctly remember sitting through one
day and as I was like a year or so into
living in that world as a tactical
leader watching him on the other side of
the screen and he kind of pushes back in
his chair and he goes kind of took his
glasses off and says okay here's where I
think we are like that was a really bad
night we had lost somebody you know and
here's our winnings I don't I don't know
exactly why that's happened but they are
getting better it seems like this I mean
it was this really raw and honest
conversation and I just thought holy
[ __ ] like this is like I'm in the same
room with this person and he's being
real so we're not prepared remarks he
didn't yeah he was he wasn't
sugar-coated right and he wasn't it was
just like you were three people in a
room going what's going on right now and
I I realize like that that is real
leadership he's stepping it unscripted
sharing what he knows what's worried
about it that know that what I like
about this is it wasn't a conference
call so much as it was an opportunity to
be a voyeur like the meeting was
actually happening in a small scale in
that room with probably four or five
people he just gave everybody he invited
everybody the opportunity to listen into
his small meeting basically well yes and
his small conversations because as it
grew over time you would have literally
I mean imagine they're 7 thousand people
watching this conversation right now but
the next person that talks to you you're
the three or four star general at CEO is
in that world it would be some young
leader you know half his age literally
getting off a helicopter wiping the dust
off and saying who just did something
great or just got their butts kicked I
would say okay here's what we thinks
going on center lights so it's a
point-to-point conversation but
everybody's watching going oh man that's
so important how did you guys control
for 7,000 people who want to tell you
their opinions yeah yeah
so we I mean we were doing a lot of work
right now I'll push it the PlayBook
we're trying to release out to everybody
so they get their heads around it and
structure is important like know how to
use your technology you you have faces
up always use video have agendas up
there have someone that controls that it
keeps us on time on the agenda something
that works yeah so you know whether
you're on zoom or Microsoft etc etc
there's creative ways to say when I'm
Weber's talking is gonna be on the left
side of my screen there's gonna be a
controller behind the scenes walking
through an agenda we're gonna use big
chat rooms to hang information in we're
gonna use sub chat rooms up on a
point-to-point conversation I can
remotely throw my hand up and the
controller can say wait Chris has a
question or just can how do you know how
do you know how to choose you know
lieutenant blah-dee-blah who just
stepped off a helicopter versus you know
lieutenant-colonel sitting in you know
HQ back there you know like hi down when
they both raise their hand and say I
want to give you my opinion how do you
how do you choose in a computer ya know
it's funny and this will happen really
fast me everybody's going to this right
now and so a few things happen one
people learn how to loot use the chat
rooms more effectively because that's
where you want the majority of your
traffic and the other is there's always
gonna be Colonel so-and-so that wants to
grandstand but they do it two or three
times and when it's tens or hundreds or
thousands of people they quickly get the
message to page stop stop with that
right you're just wasting everybody's
time basically when this starts it's
gonna be a bit of a cluster and bait and
if you're doing it everyday for you know
how long did you do them for an hour 60
to 90 minutes seven days a week for a
year straight so if we start do if
companies start doing this if we start
doing this for 60 90 minutes a day every
single day it is an obviously a small
company probably doesn't need to be that
long but but basically what ends I mean
it's gonna be a cluster to start but if
you you start getting a rhythm over the
course of the probably a few days it
probably clicks and pretty quickly I
would imagine yeah very quickly I mean
well Crystal group 100 folks were spread
around the world pretty complex the work
we do we started this two weeks ago
because we could see this thing coming
and we took our weekly cadence and we
said every day seven days a week 9:00
a.m. Eastern because we have people
around the world and anybody can dial in
we have families dialed in like families
can listen in right because we're all in
this together so it's important that
spouses know what's going on with a
company etc and the you know the analogy
always uses is you need it it needs to
be structured and unstructured right
place right into all the way you think
about stuff obviously the analogy I use
for business leaders is think of it like
jazz right everybody lists if you like
jazz you and you understand it it's it's
not all people being creative all the
time there's a very very rigid bassline
that most non experts can't really hear
but people don't just don't show up and
start being creative they they set a
base tone and then they know where they
can be creative I'm having a very
structured approach and disciplined
agenda gives you the the discipline and
cadence and then also says now here's
the time where we can think freely is it
is it always the same agenda is it was
the same sort of outline or is it does
it change depending on one it will have
to change if you're keeping up with the
pace around you right start with
something take your best shot
be honest with people and say look
here's what we think it's gonna be
different smart smart smart and then the
tweaks will get smaller smaller over
time okay this is great because you know
one of the things that I've also been
thinking is that that as shocking as
this all feels it's not unprecedented in
business you know
the internet showed up and it put a lot
of companies out of business because
they couldn't adapt
you know you know video stores went out
of business because they couldn't adapt
and like
facing change and needing to adapt one's
own business is not unprecedented in
business this is more sudden right and
the companies that are doubling down on
like how do we do more of what we used
to do they're the ones that are going to
struggle the most the ones that can go
through the flex and say okay how do we
take advantage of what's different now
and come out of this a different
stronger better company
yeah could be
could be completely different yeah I
would assume you'll come out of this
differently right one of the back to our
sort of origins and all this you know
probably a year into McChrystal driving
this change he started telling people
openly cuz he had the platform to do it
you know what I heard I heard a long
time when are we going back to the old
way of doing business
yeah I think we've all realized this is
the new normal you know yeah and we're
learning how to thrive in it right yeah
and you look I mean the parallels are so
strikingly similar right I mean this
spread of a violent ideology through
human networks spread of the disease and
we weren't able to take this huge system
and get ahead of that network dynamic
it's really good
Chris thank you I'm gonna give this a
try I really appreciate it thank you may
good luck look you soon hey buddy
[Music]
you